(distant conversations)
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Good Excuse" by
Trevor Wesley)
- [Gary] Done. It's not
worth the conversation.
I'll make that investment to
get your full time camera guy
because you're right,
you have the right thing.
DRock's literally right behind
me right now so I'm saying it a
little louder because
he's gonna start vetting.
Okay, give me a thought,
give me some final three.
Alright, I'll make, yeah.
By the way,
if you're in Afghanistan
I'll make the investment.
You guys got me a big gift.
- Can you actually--
- [Gary] I love coconuts.
- Gary, thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
(group laughter)
That was weird.
- Stop it, Gary!
It's too late.
Super live.
Wish I could juggle.
- [Woman] There's
only two, but...
- Can you juggle?
- [Man] Yeah, probably
not coconuts though.
- [Man 2] That was pretty close.
- Well, no, this is two.
You got to do three
to actually juggle, right?
- [Man] Yes, you're right.
- I don't know how to juggle.
You know how to juggle?
- [Man 3] Definitely not.
- I know how to juggle
the universe but coconuts,
nope.
(DRock laughs)
Okay, Cort, looking for job.
I'll work for free and
start off doing anything
even clean toilets.
GaryVee, I promise
to be an asset.
Alright, Courtney,
VaynerMedia looking for job.
I'll work for free and start
off doing anything
even cleaning toilets.
GaryVee, I promise
to be an asset.
Courtney you've got a meeting.
Show me.
I put up my two fingers for
them to take a screenshot,
did you see this?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's everywhere.
Oh my God, look at this.
- [DRock] (chuckles) Wow.
- [Gary] I want to go
back on Facebook Live,
excuse me, Instagram Live
but I'm not gonna say a word.
I'm just gonna do that.
I want to see how many
people know what it is.
("Good Excuse" by
Trevor Wesley)
Alright, I can't
do that any more.
Only because the 1500 people
I can't assume they were in the
last stream and
I feel like a dick.
Anyway, I don't know if you guys
saw this earlier but it's crazy
if you look at people to
tagged me on Instagram.
Can other people see that view?
'Cause that's my
view of people tag.
- [DRock] Yeah, you can go.
- What, you can go into search?
- [Tyler] If I go
to your profile.
- Got it.
Anyway, earlier today, just
want to give a big shout out to
everybody that was part of my
earlier stream where
I said put this up.
It's so sad that
I that I didn't go to,
you can go to my
account and see it?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Other people tag.
So check this out, if you
go to my account after this,
go to my account and then see
the little part where you're
tagged and I guess you
can see it on my account and
see where I was tagged.
So many of you of the 2600 of
you tagged the
photo of me doing this.
So you screenshot this and
then you guys left comments,
then you posted in your
Instagram and you tagged me and
then you said you know why you
follow me and things of that
nature and obviously people
did that in Stories and used the
@GaryVee and I just
want to say thank you.
That was amazing.
The earlier, you know what's
sad about Instagram Live is it
doesn't record or save
to your camera roll.
And so, DRock wasn't there.
That was my fault
and I went crazy.
How many people were a
part of the last session?
Just say, "Part of it,"
so other people can see.
It was crazy because
I was so fired up about this.
Obviously this last week, last
10 days have been a remarkable
virality for me.
So many of you, actually how
many of you in here are new in
the last two weeks.
Also put that, I'm curious.
But I think it just been
it's been crazy the momentum.
Enormous growth
here on Instagram.
Obviously the new
features have worked out.
The 60 Second Club
has worked out.
The videos of been fire.
Oh, DRock, what
about that minute,
10 second video
that I made yesterday.
- [DRock] I sent that to Eliot.
- Yeah, they got it already?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Love it.
Anyway, just wanted
to say thank you.
The new call in show
The #AskGaryVee call in show,
the new format.
I hope you've checked that out.
Go check that up on YouTube and
Facebook but most of all I just
wanted to thank everybody
because basically the whole
conversation was
King noobie,
look at all these noobies.
Will Press, new.
Sport JA, new.
Desean, Boyd, new. Love it.
Part of it, part of it, love it.
Anyway, I miss you too Kobe.
Anyway, I was basically going
crazy earlier this morning and
did this thing because I wanted
people to share because I was
explaining what I want to
accomplish here which is
I'm on a mission, and
I mean a real mission,
to change the current narrative
of people that are trying to
change your lives, get motivated
and then start their businesses
and become successful.
And I want to make it a
practical conversation and
I want to destroy, and I mean
destroy all these people that
are bottom feeding and genuinely
doing the wrong thing by
creating content and
selling it to guys.
$300 e-books, courses, you know.
Yes, sir? Need me?
- [Man 4] Anything
else for these guys?
- Like in life?
- [Man 4] We got about 25
minutes before we got to break.
- Not a whole, whole lot.
- [Man 4] Tricks for them.
- We'll figure something out.
Cool, I'll come back.
- [Man 4] Okay.
- Anyway, I just wanted to
create clarity because there's
so many new people in here and
really I wanted to get people to
understand why I'm so desperate
to continue to build my audience
because I basically want every
single person on Earth to pay
attention to what I have to say
because I'm very
confident of two things.
One, for me, I know that I'm
not asking for your money.
I went on this
great rant, DRock,
I can't force it now
so it's a lost moment.
But I was like
I don't want your money.
I was like I don't
want your money.
I want you to keep your
money in your pocket.
I just want your attention so
I can show you what to do so
you don't go and spend it
on these bullshit things.
So you do understand
there's no shortcuts.
It was just like
I want you to keep your
fucking money
in your pocket. You know?
And so, I'm just
trying to set the course.
Trying to set the course and so
trying to get people to pass me
on because there's
people bottom feeding.
There's people
doing the wrong thing.
There's people that
don't have the right intent.
And they're taking advantage
of people when they're in a sad
place or when they're
nervous or insecure.
And so, automobile,
exotica, there's your shout out.
Lewis Howes, what's up, baby?
I want to make
people to know that
I'm focused.
I'm focused on getting
all, all the attention.
I love you back, Erin.
All of the attention so
I can do a couple things.
Number one, my number
one goal for all 2700,
2800 of you is one,
first and foremost,
to build self-esteem.
I want all of you to be more
confident tomorrow than you were
yesterday because you're
spending time paying attention
my crap because
it's very simple,
my crap speaks to this this;
Stop worrying about
what you're not and
start focusing on who you are.
We all suck at shit.
Do you know how quickly I would
be fired if I had Tyler's job?
- If I had DRock's job.
- [Gary] Yeah, and
if DRock had my job.
Yeah, we'd all be fired because
that's not what we're about.
When you figure out what you're
good at and where your strengths
lie, then you will win and I am
tired of your mom saying you're
a loser or your boyfriend saying
you can't or your older brother
because he's insecure, not
giving you love or self-esteem
so that you can succeed.
I'm tired of the people
closest to you because of their
insecurities and weaknesses
giving you feedback and putting
you in a path that keeps you
suppressed because they got
their insecurities.
Do you know why, do you guys
know why I don't have a process
of charging you?
You know why
there's no rabbit hole
for you to give me your money?
It's actually quite simple.
It's 'cause I make
my money elsewhere.
Do you know why
I give you my best advice and
why I build you up?
Because I genuinely
think you can't beat me.
That I think I'm better.
That if you fully
replicate everything that I do,
I will still beat you
'cause I'm hungrier,
I'm a machine.
You know kind of, do
you know I fucking day,
you know I went I traveled
I flew from LA to Atlanta for a
meeting and then
flew back on Sunday and
you know how unphased I was?
Yeah I knew I had some dark
under my eyes in DailyVee.
Lighting wasn't great and
I naturally have them and
I was tired as fuck.
I'm just, I'm just
stronger than you.
I'm just better than
you and believe it or
not that's not a negative.
It's what gives me the ability
to give you everything I've got.
I'll give you everything.
I will give you
everything I have.
I will give you the best advice.
If you're really smart you'll
pay attention to what I do and
you can leverage that.
I will encourage you I will
shoot it to you straight when
you suck some shit.
I will do everything that's in
your best interest because if
I do everything in your best
interest you will love me more.
That's why I have
the best community.
I don't have the biggest.
I have the best.
I have the best because the
quality of the 3200 people in
this room is higher
and I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why it's higher.
It's higher because the
majority of you figured out why
I'm different than the
rest of the market.
You've figured it out.
You figured out,
you have figured out,
you guys have figured
out that I'm different.
That my, my...
Hey Rupert.
Rup, Rup, what am I doing?
I'm going to film and then him?
- [Rupert] Yep.
- Cool. Good
to see you, brother.
- [Man 5] How you doing?
- How was your flight?
- [Man 5] It was alright.
- Cool, man.
I'll see you probably 30, 25.
We'll have to move
it around, alright?
- [Man 5] Yeah.
- I'm just telling my community
why I'm giving them the
best content in the world.
That's it.
I'm just better than everybody
else and that allows me to give
it to you more and better and
cleaner and you'll wait for the
other shoe to drop and cynicism
will prevail and you'll be
confused by others and a lot of
you are following people that
aren't bringing value but
they're selling you what you
want to hear.
I'm selling you what
you don't want to hear.
I'm selling you it's
gonna take a long time.
That you have to
figure out your skills.
That it's hard.
That it's a grind,
that it's not attractive.
That you might not be
doing it the right way.
I'm telling you that all of you
might not be talented enough.
I'm telling you the hard stuff
so you guys like me AKA
give me your attention
which I'm so thankful for and
I will never take for granted
and the reason I engage with you
guys is because I'm so thankful.
And some of my friends ask me
why waste my time being GaryVee
'cause they recognize that,
they recognize that
I can make more
money not spending time.
There's a lot of moneymaking
I could do in the 17 minutes
that I'm doing here.
What they don't realize is
I've already made enough money.
Meaning of course
I want to buy the Jets
but love and community
is the greatest.
This is the craziest
feeling of my life.
The craziest.
I'm coming.
The craziest feeling of my
life and I appreciate you guys.
And I will always give you my
best and forever and it's time
that you guys start
really paying attention.
I implore you guys to
really pay attention to who.
Dave Sweethome
says Jets still suck, too.
Alright, Dave.
Let me see, Dave.
This is where I get
a little gangster.
Dave Sweethome says,
"Jets still suck though."
I'm clicking on his face.
Hide Live from Dave.
Boom, see ya, Dave.
(DRock laughs)
Yes. Dave no longer can
see your live stream.
Sorry, Dave.
Hope you continue to consume my
content on regular Instagram.
Anyway, the one place
I'm emotional and
not practical is the Jets.
Don't fuck with my Jets.
I will hang up on your ass
like you saw on DailyVee and
I will block you.
By the way, Dave is the first
human being I've ever blocked.
People have come on,
said I'm a scam artist,
I'm the worst, fuck you,
you've seen the comments.
No block.
I never hide any of my comments.
You say the Jets suck,
you're fucking out.
Anyway, love you guys.
Have a great day.
I will talk to you soon and
I apprecaite your attention and
I will never take it for granted
and I wish you
super duper, duper well.
Oh Kaplan Pud, let
me just put up Pud.
I have to go to this meeting.
There's Pud pinned.
This guy right here,
Phil Kaplan, beast.
Internet beast, internet beast.
Beast. Beast.
So help me understand this,
what do you want to do?
Because I think you, right now,
you're looking for money which
I love 'cause cash is
oxygen and I appreciate that.
Now do you live at home?
- [Woman 2] I do live at home.
I lived at the dorms.
Right now, actually that's why
I did my brownie hustle so I can
pay to live at the dorms but
right now I'm gonna live with
my mom so, yeah.
- Good.
So what I'm trying to figure out
is like how grimy you can be?
Meaning I want to give you
the most patience that you can.
That's the big thing, right?
You know about my
self-awareness thing and
that's awesome
because that's good.
How about the patience thing?
Are you buying into my patience
thing or is that like hard to
think about eating
shit until you're 27,
for the next seven
years of your life?
- [Woman 2] I like to think long
term and I like to think I think
long term but I feel like
because I'm so young I want to
do things right away.
- Before you sell
self-awareness,
I think the best thing to
happen is for you to use your
self-awareness about you to
become successful so that you
have something to stand on when
you talk about self-awareness
and/or
you have to go and get a
degree and sit on the back of
psychology and that whole world.
Those are your only two options
because nobody's gonna give a
shit about your opinion
on self-awareness as a
22, 20-year-old just saying
I like self-awareness.
They're just not gonna care.
- [Woman 2] That's true.
- You know?
They'll take your opinion.
What's that?
- [Woman 2] School
kind of sucks, Gary.
- Who the fuck
are you talking to?
(woman 2 laughs)
I mean I know.
And/or you deploy that skill
set for you to be successful and
then you attributed to that,
you documented that,
and then you sold on that.
I think you should spend
the next month or two
thinking about the
things you love the most.
Music, food,
fashion, art, I don't care.
And that you should find
something to sell and then use
your CPA skills,
your social skills,
your selling skills and try
to build something you sell.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- Sell something.
- [Woman 2] Right.
So, with my two grand,
what do you think
I should do right now?
- Keep it and/or
spend it on the
initial inventory on the
products you need to sell.
Alright, I got to go.
I'm filming something.
I hate to, I've gone way over.
I'm enjoying this conversation.
Listen to me,--
- [Woman 2] Okay.
- you're 20.
- Do you know that if you
lived an entire 'nother life,
like you died right now, and
became alive again and lived
your whole life you'd still
be one year younger than me.
- [Woman 2] (laughs) Yeah,
that's crazy to think about.
- I need you to think about that
because I need you to
understand one thing.
If you decide to give me
any more of your attention,
all I want you to hear
is one word: patience.
Go work for your cousin and make
$9 an hour in painting or 14 or
whatever the fuck he's gonna
pay you because you respect him,
trust him and he's been
successful and what you're doing
is you're getting paid
to observe his behavior.
- [Woman 2] I love that.
- Good.
- [Woman 2] God, Gary,
you get my blood flowing.
(Gary laughs)
("Good Excuse"
by Trevor Wesley)
- I like that.
So, wait a minute.
Let's go, right here, okay.
Yeah, give me one of those.
Give me--
- [Tyler] One, one, one.
- [Gary] Yeah. Yeah.
That's why we're
living what we're living.
- [Man 6] How come you guys
wear the same sneakers today?
- Somebody sent
us the same pair.
- It's his energy.
I'm gonna tell you like,
I didn't know of you before.
- [Gary] Of course,
I get it. I get it.
- I started to follow you and
look at the videos I feel like
also coming from nothing
and working when you see
someone who's
passionate about that--
- [Gary] And who wants
it for everybody else.
No really, this is so authentic.
This is so authentic.
That's what works to your point.
If I do this, if I sell, again,
you know what I really need for
you for my own fucking ego and
competitive juices and you gave
it to me with the
(censored), you're obviously,
you want to make this deal
happen and I'm telling you this
is only going to fall apart
if something crazy happens.
- [Man 5] What's a
mind-blowing success?
- I know what matters for you
but what would the market be
like how the fuck did
they sell, what is that?
Do you know?
(group crosstalk)
- [Man 5] Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] Talk to you.
Alright, time to go.
- [Tyler] Yes.
- [Gary] I'm late.
- [Tyler] Car's downstairs.
- Okay, I'll see you guys later.
- [Tyler] Yeah, and we're taking a
separate car just 'cause it's
easier in the morning
- Okay. So I'll see you guys.
- [Tyler] See you
at the airport.
- See you later.
- [DRock] Do you
want to say anything?
- Good day.
Good meetings.
I don't know, what
did you get today?
Secret meetings.
- [DRock] A little FaceTime.
- A little FaceTime,
listen, I mean,
I'm working here.
(laughs) That's
what I have to say.
I'm working here.
("Good Excuse" by Trevor Wesley)